who's that you must be new
that is first Wayne
this away Clark Kent Daily Planet what's
your position on the bat vigilante in
Gotham civil liberties are being
trampled on their city
people living in fear thinks he's above
the law
Daily Planet criticizing notices think
they're above the laws don't hypocrite
what you're saying
considering every time your hero saves a
cat out of a tree you read off-piste
editorial about an alien you could burn
the whole place down most of the world
doesn't share your opinion mr. Wayne
maybe it's Gotham City and me you just
have a bad history with pretty dress
like clowns
boys hmm Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I
love it
I love bringing people together how are
we next hi hello Lex it is a pledge out
Wow
that is a good grip you should not pick
a fight with this person you know the
oldest lie in America senator the power
can be innocent
go to war as some [ __ ] brought the war
to us you know you can't win this it's
suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
Son of Krypton versus bat of Gotham
you're psychotic it's a three syllable
word for any thought too big for little
minds
sign-u learn what it means to be a man
down I wanted it you began already
man won't kill God
together we'll do it
what have you done
Oh
she would you
I thought yours with you